joining me now is legendary
singer-songwriter don mclean dom mclean
thank you so much for joining piers
morgan uncensored it's a great honor
thank you very much that's lovely for
you to say that thank you you know i was
seven years old when american pie went
to number one in the billboard charts
and i probably sung it every year at a
party
since then
so for 50 years i've been singing your
anthem how does how do you feel about
that
well um as a sort of a folklorist i
think it's become kind of a folk song
you know uh in the last few years i've
seen them
tear down statues and tear down
buildings and everything changes but the
song lives
in the minds and the hearts of millions
of people you can't tear it down
it's more indestructible than all those
things
i mean there are there are a few songs
in the world which have that kind of
resonance as somebody who wrote it when
you were back in your in your 20s
obviously you could never have imagined
just how big it would get but did you
feel
as you were writing it that it could be
special
well i felt that i was a special
songwriter i was quite egotistical
in that sense i felt i had
certain gifts and i wanted to
i never had anybody tell me what to do
on a record i would write what i wanted
or i wouldn't sign the contract
so i was in complete control and that
album american pie
i had all the songs except the one that
i wanted which was the big one
and i spent 10 years really thinking
about buddy holly before i finally
came up with that first part because i
wanted a big song about america
and when i came up with that i said you
know i'll tie that
up
with the ideas that i have for this song
and then i i knew i was really on my way
and i don't write songs like most other
people do and therefore
i'm not nearly as successful because i
don't have a formula of any sort i do
something once and then that's it
they'll never be an american pie too or
anything like that this will be a
staggeringly impertinent question but
i'm going to ask it anyway
i've been trying to work out how much
money you must have made from american
pie given i assume it is playing
somewhere in the world at any given
moment
well it's see i'm an album artist and um
i was just on good morning america and
they presented me with a plaque
that i was surprised me that i have been
certified as having sold over 50 million
albums worldwide wow people buy my
albums that's why they come to the shows
of course
everybody knows american pie but if
everybody that knows that song came to
my shows i'd be selling out stadiums
so you see they they know the song but
it's my fans who know the albums and
those songs like you know crossroads and
empty chairs and babylon and
vincent and castles in the air and i
love you so
these songs are known to millions and
millions of people but the big the big
boy you know the big tree in the forest
of course is always american pie what i
love about you don is that you always
play it for your fans you don't
understand why
big stars don't play their biggest hits
because that's obviously what fans want
to hear when you when you rode american
pie in
obviously we started with the buddy
holly a bit we all know that but it's
it's it in many ways it was an anthem
for the state of america and how you
felt about it at the time how do you
feel
america has changed in the last 50 years
well i tried to get the craziness of
america
as well as the the hugeness of it
into the song the size of it it had to
be a massive song for this massive
country full of contradictions full of
love and anger and hatred and creative
genius all at once
and that was all in the back of my crazy
mind i was writing this for myself but i
must say that i think
america is getting more crazy and less
sane
you know i wrote a song called prime
time a few years later which was about
seeing everything through the television
and america as a game show
and we almost had the game show
president here a couple of years ago so
i was laughing at it i was thinking man
this song was right on you know it was
45 years old
but uh yeah it was this idea and and
also that music was being made
mechanically which it is i will venture
to say that in 10 years computers will
make better songs than i hear on the
radio now really because they'll
yeah they'll put all the beatles songs
and all of every classical music all
kinds of stuff into this computer and
they're going to come up with some
amazing things the p the stuff i hear on
the radio is extremely
pedestrian
[Music]
very interesting i wanted to talk to you
about the events of last week in america
in particular because there was another
horrendous mass shooting at a school
and you were due to perform at the nra
conference
two days later and you pulled that and
you pulled out of that of that
performance why did you pull out and
what did you think about the shooting
what what can america do
about this ongoing epidemic of gun
violence
well i pulled out because it would be a
horrendously bad taste to be there and
the only reason i did the show was
because i i kind of like western things
you know western guns western rifles
indian things i thought
maybe i'd go and see some cool
six guns or something and so have asked
me to sing all right i'll sing
then this thing happened and i said oh i
can't do this this is because i'm an
independent
you know i'm always doing something
that's making somebody on one side or
the other scratch their head you know i
have my conservative friend says why
have you written the ballot of george
floyd which will be on my next record
and then i have my liberal friends why
would you go play for them you know well
because i like western guns you know
that was but i didn't think about it
that way then i said no i can't do this
and i think that
i heard
again now i'm listening and hearing
things
that
there are people objecting to background
checks well that's that's again the
insanity right that i'm talking about
and there are people allowing these uh
assault rifles that's insanity
that is not for hunting or for
protecting yourself
and but if i may just digress for a
moment the idea of this second amendment
was really to have uh be able to fight
off the army back 200 years ago 200
years ago the army had a musket and a
saber and a horse and the average guy
had a musket and a saber and a horse
now there are elements in this
particular area who want to have
everything the army has
you know surface-to-air missiles you
know uh bazookas
so we've reached a point where
and again
you're in you're in the area of madness
you had a great quote donald i wanted to
replay to you you said there was very
little left on your bucket list i've
seen everything i've been everywhere
i've done it all i love that
well it's the truth and uh
and one thing i'll say is that uh
you know i've done things right and i've
done things wrong but i uh but it's all
down on me i don't blame anybody else we
all make mistakes in life but uh
i don't say i've done it all either i
did it if i did it right it's because i
did it right if i did it wrong it's
because i did it wrong
and um
and one thing i would say is that
i like to know things you know and i
like to learn about things and one thing
i want to tell you is i followed your
career
and i loved your tv show when you took
over for larry king oh thank you um
i loved your tv show i still remember
many interviews that you did you were a
very very good interviewer and i always
made a point of watching it and i still
know about all the trouble you cause on
morning television with
your wonderful opinions which i most of
the time agree with completely
says that makes me happy thank you
thank you uh i just wanted to to play
you a message actually because you've
become extra famous in the uk because
our champion world heavyweight boxing
hero tyson fury loves to sing american
pie when he wins and we have a message
for you from the great man
hey tyson fury here this is a special
message to don mclean
i hear you on the pace morgan show
tonight don
absolutely smash it brother um i loved
our rendition of american pie it was
absolutely fantastic um hi pierce
hope you're having a good time guys
don't do anything i wouldn't
and smash it good luck guys all the best
god bless you
how cool is that well you know i was i
was i was going to tell tyson i love to
meet him someday i love him he is what
boxing has needed um he is a lovable
champion and he's a great champion and i
wanted to tell him
that um whenever i get in trouble now
i'm going to say that i have him as my
best friend and i'm going to warn
anybody who's trying to mess with me
that i have him on speed dial you know
what i mean
and and i wanted to say back to him that
if he has any trouble from like paul
simon or someone like that that i'll
handle that i can i can take paul simon
don it's been brilliant to talk to you
you've got a uk tour coming uh 11th of
september it starts in cardiff you'll be
coming around the country
tell me a little bit about the uk and
your feelings for the fans here
well you know they're the most devoted
and
heartfelt uh
fans i've really loved these years these
many many tours that i've done i've
never had a show
that i didn't want to do
and i've never met anybody that i didn't
like
it's amazing i have a fan over there
named david new
who back in 1978 had me tattooed on his
back
he's still there
and he was the first person to ever do
that and i warned him i said are you
sure you want to do this because you
know you might decide you don't like me
sometime you know and uh he's no i'm
going through we didn't no doubt about
it and so
he did it
yeah final question for you don if you
could look back over your entire life
and career if i had the power to let you
relive
one moment again what would you choose
oh my word
i that's a hard question i've had
so many many many wonder i believe such
a wonderful life with people
you know
applauding me and
so much stuff that i've done
i think
i wish
that i could have
uh known my father better
right
yeah it's taken a moment
to
to know him but he was scottish and um
he was 56 when he died and he was pretty
burned out anyway but
um
i i'm sorry about that i would like to
have known him better
it was an interesting time in your life
because i think you were 15 weren't you
when he died and he
he never really supported you in your
home of becoming an entertainer
well i knew he was going to die i kept
telling everybody in the family i said
i think he's going to die and
my grandmother would say what are you
talking about i said well i can see it
they couldn't see it
and he did he right in front of me
it happened
i have this ability sometimes to
know what is going to happen before it
does
it's it's served me very well keeping me
out of trouble and
also i've always known a lot of times
what was coming around the corner not
every time but
i would have a a nagging
feeling about something
and it takes over
and it's the same
uh
antenna i think that sends the songs to
me
and you're i'm really not terribly
smart or i don't read music i don't
write music but i have these visions
sometimes
i can see the song and then i write what
i see
and the words come to me because only
certain words
will do
i love the english language
that's another reason why i love the
british i love the attention to detail
and i love
the the civility for the most part and
the english language and uh it's so
important to me
and don what do you think your father
would have made of your incredible
success
i think he would have died again you
know i mean i think he would have just
rolled over dead i mean i don't think
you'd ever believe it
you know he thought i was destined to be
uh um
lost really you've had an amazing career
uh don and i'm sad that your father
didn't get to see
what you made with it because you know
it would have been a wonderful thing i
think for him to realize that you were
right to have that dream
because the dream came true and you've
lived an amazing life and it's a real
pleasure to talk to you thank you very
much
thank you